Cloverfield is one of the most curious franchises
in Hollywood, with just a few seemingly disjointed
movies and a short manga comic to its name.
So what's the story behind these stories,
and just how did the franchise come to be? This
is the untold truth of the Cloverfield franchise.
J.J. Abrams has built his career on
echoing genre movies of the past,
so it probably won't come as a surprise to
find that he thought up Cloverfield as a
way of paying tribute to classic kaiju movies.
However, the circumstances that informed this
idea were rooted in a more specific personal
experience — one that made Abrams realize
the sorry status of American-made monster
movies. In an interview, Abrams explained:
"I got the idea when I went to Japan [...]
and saw all these Godzilla toys in the
shops. I realised that America hasn’t
had a monster movie to call its own,
not since King Kong all those years ago anyway,
and thought it was time to change that."
From this toy store encounter sprang
a desire that fueled the creation of
not just the original Cloverfield, but an
entire sprawling franchise. In the process,
Abrams did indeed create an ultra-intense monster;
one that was more than capable of standing
up against cinema's biggest beasts.
One of the most evocative aspects of
Cloverfield's marketing campaign was its
emphasis on the beheading
of the Statue of Liberty.
The decapitated head closed out the
film's initial teaser trailer with a bang,
while a headless Lady Liberty featured as the
centerpiece of Cloverfield's poster. By lingering
on this image, Cloverfield instantly crafted an
aura of fear and dread around its plot. Obviously,
the Statue of Liberty is something Americans
assume will always stand in New York City. When
that gets threatened by an unknown menace — well,
that's bound to send a chill up anyone's spine.
Lady Liberty's decapitation was
actually inspired by the marketing
materials for a classic 1980s action movie.
As Cloverfield director Matt Reeves told IGN:
"The inspiration came from the
poster of Escape from New York.
The poster had an image on it of the head
of the Statue of Liberty and that image was
nowhere in the movie! And it's
an incredibly provocative image."
The title for the original Cloverfield didn't
just spring up out of thin air. In fact,
the project went under several working
titles before settling on its final moniker.
During production, Cloverfield was known
by a number of different temporary titles,
including "Slusho," "Chocolate
Outrage," and "Cheese."
Even as the movie's release date approached,
Cloverfield had no title to speak of, with
the teaser trailer only promising a release date.
It was later reported that the film might end up
going by the name Wreck. As it turned out, this
all helped to keep the first Cloverfield movie
cloaked under a veil of secrecy. The project's
marketing was defined by its cryptic nature,
and all that constant speculation over
the title helped keep up that reputation.
Cloverfield's second trailer, in November
2007, would eventually give the movie its name,
while the movie's follow-ups would further
turn Cloverfield into a full-blown brand.
Monster movies tend to function as much as
sociopolitical commentary as they do opportunities
to watch huge beasts topple buildings. Just look
at the 1954 movie Godzilla, which is a clear
reflection on Japan's nuclear anxiety. In the
case of Cloverfield, director Matt Reeves had a
very specific idea of what this particular monster
movie, captured through the lens of found footage,
was meant to say about the time in which it
was released. Reeves told Shock Till You Drop:
"Cloverfield very much speaks to the fear and
anxieties of our time, how we live our lives.
Constantly documenting things
and putting them up on YouTube,
sending people videos through email — we felt it
was very applicable to the way people feel now."
Reeves also observed how one moment,
in which the lead movie's protagonists encounter
another person filming everything, was meant to
remind people that there was more happening in
the wider world of Cloverfield. He continued:
"Media is so much an aspect of our lives today
that even evoking that idea was exciting to us.
That there could be different stories out there."
"You still filming?"
"Yeah. People are gonna wanna know
how it all went down."
While the beast itself was absent from the
vast majority of the marketing for Cloverfield,
the film itself does eventually feature
the creature that has come to be dubbed
Clover. In the film, Clover only enjoys a
fleeting on-screen presence, with the brevity
of its appearances meant to heighten the sense of
fear and uncertainty felt by both the characters
and the audience. Despite its minimal screen
time, though, a whole lot of care went into this
creature — particularly in figuring out which
real-world animals would come to inspire it.
The primary element emphasized in the monster's
behavior was terror. Rather than maliciously
choosing to rampage across New York City,
Clover was designed to evoke wild animals,
such as elephants or horses, that have
become terrified and begun to run amok.
This lent an extra sense of unpredictability to
Clover and its actions. There was no evil plan
driving it, nor any complex motivation behind
all that chaos. Clover was simply engaging in
random fits of destruction because,
above all else, it was frightened.
On a visual level, underwater creatures
such as piranhas were channeled into the
design of the monster's face — a nod to
how Clover is an extraterrestrial being
that crash landed in Earth's oceans.
Before he won an Oscar for Best Director for
his work on La La Land, and even prior to
directing Whiplash, Damien Chazelle was just
another artist looking for his big break.
At one point, that break looked like it might
come from Bad Robot Productions. J.J. Abrams and
company enlisted Chazelle to write and direct
the original version of 10 Cloverfield Lane,
then titled Valencia. Abrams
later told Empire magazine:
"Actually, [Damien Chazelle] was
originally coming on as a director
as well, and he was working on
the script to direct. [...] He
did incredible work with [aspects of]
plot and character with his draft."
The eventual director of 10 Cloverfield Lane,
Dan Trachtenberg, had nothing but positive
things to say about the feature's original
filmmaker. He later told The Q&A Podcast:
"I have so many things to thank him for. [Because
he made Whiplash,] I got a chance to make a movie,
and he did a great job with the script.
He really gifted me with so many things."
When 10 Cloverfield Lane was in production,
its cast and crew knew it only as Valencia,
a low-budget thriller hailing from Bad Robot
Productions. However, as production went on,
something changed. Before long, Valencia had
become a spiritual sequel to Cloverfield,
and the title was altered to 10 Cloverfield Lane.
"Crazy is building your ark after
the flood has already come!"
Rather than being the result of some brilliant
plan kept secret by everyone involved in the film,
however, attaching this project to the name
Cloverfield was actually a last-minute switch.
Speaking to MovieWeb about how this change
came about, director Dan Trachtenberg said:
"We wrote an original screenplay. Cloverfield
was not in our mind at the time. During the
development process, the idea came up
that it could be in the Clover-verse.
We were a bit surprised initially, but now when
you see the movie; it makes a lot of sense in
terms of tone, twists, turns, and the thriller
aspect. It was definitely the right decision."
By attaching the Cloverfield name to
10 Cloverfield Lane, this new thriller
was able to stand out more easily in a crowded
marketplace. Moreover, following up Cloverfield
with an otherwise standalone project allowed
the film to function as a mostly separate
narrative — rather than simply supporting itself
on Cloverfield plot points and shout-outs.
For years after the original
Cloverfield was released,
news would occasionally come to light suggesting
that a direct follow-up was in development.
Just a few weeks after the original debuted,
director Matt Reeves even told Rotten Tomatoes
that they were considering a number of active
concepts as to where a follow-up might go.
However, the busy schedules of all those
involved in the first Cloverfield — and
particularly J.J. Abrams — was constantly cited
as a reason why the project wasn't moving forward.
With the release of 10 Cloverfield Lane,
Abrams finally had a chance to reveal why
audiences hadn't seen another movie set in
the world of Cloverfield. He told Fandango:
"We had so much fun making
Cloverfield that when we were done,
we felt like we were done with that
movie. And there were a lot of ideas [for
a follow-up] [...] A lot of things were thrown
around. But we now live in that post-Godzilla,
post-Pacific Rim era, where those movies
have been made. So what would we do?"
With this in mind, Abrams and company
opted instead to pursue a more spiritual
sequel to the first movie — and
10 Cloverfield Lane was born.
Much like 10 Cloverfield Lane, The Cloverfield
Paradox wasn't always meant to be a part of the
Cloverfield franchise. Originally, it
was just a standalone science fiction
movie called The God Particle. However,
according to the film's writer Oren Uziel,
it wasn't long before it became attached to an
already existing franchise. Uziel told Collider:
"[The Cloverfield Paradox] was written before
10 Cloverfield Lane and the expanded Cloverfield
universe even existed as a thing. [...] I don't
know exactly when it became a Cloverfield
movie. [...] I think everyone just knew,
if it fits — and it does — into that Cloverfield
world, it should, and it can only help."
Uziel emphasized that it's not easy marketing
an original movie of any kind these days,
and that The God Particle's association with the
Cloverfield name likely gave it
a fighting chance at survival.
In its long journey to release, The Cloverfield
Paradox went through a series of reshoots that
were initially shrouded in as much secrecy as
anything else in the movie. However, once the
project was officially released on Netflix, more
details emerged about what those reshoots had
entailed. Apparently, they had been focused on
adding a new Earth-bound subplot to the movie.
During a Facebook Q&A session, J.J Abrams
noted that scenes in The Cloverfield
Paradox following Michael Hamilton as he navigates
the situation on Earth were not originally part of
the script. They were added during these reshoots
at the behest of test screening audiences,
who were curious about what was happening on the
ground during the events of the main story, which
takes place in space. This subplot also helped set
up the infamous ending of The Cloverfield Paradox,
which explicitly connects the feature to the
original Cloverfield with a certain special cameo.
Clover appears and roars
Today, A Quiet Place is its own mega-franchise,
one with a widely recognizable brand name that
can generate sizable box office
returns with very little effort.
But once upon a time, the first Quiet Place
was just another original horror movie.
Not only that, but there was once a moment
where it even looked like it would even be
folded into the Cloverfield franchise.
Screenwriter Scott Beck told IndieWire:
"I guess it crossed our mind, and we had
spoken to our representatives about that
possibility. [...] We were actually talking to
an executive [at Paramount] about this film,
and it felt from pitch form
that there might be crossover."
Luckily, Paramount had
other ideas. Beck continued:
"But when we finally took the final script
in to Paramount, they saw it as a totally
different movie [...] I think in part because
conceptually it was able to stand on its own."
Given his affinity for original storytelling,
Beck was understandably relieved when Paramount
allowed A Quiet Place to stand on its own
two legs. And of course, in an ironic twist,
the finished movie became so popular
that it spawned a whole new franchise;
one entirely distinct from the Cloverfield
name… and arguably more successful, too.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.